we have an xbox series x and so last
week we asked you all for your questions
about the brand new console
so to help answer them joining myself
tam and jordan
is our resident expert michael hyam
hello mate
hey what's that you've got there
that's an xbox series x baby look at
that
oh like do you want to do like a the
lion king moment or a baby moment
all right so first of all i just want to
say absolutely
titillated to have michael heim here
talking about the new xbox
um so we got the xbox in a little while
ago and heim has had it for
what is coming too close to two weeks
now now
about a week about a week if time's a
big flat circle yeah i do that
so who knows i feel like i feel like
we've been
dealing with this whole process for
maybe two months
yes um yeah so if you haven't seen it we
have coverage up around
michael's initial experiences um we are
limited on what we can say
around it right now so the first kind of
crop of
micros coverage involves um the
backwards compatibility
aspect of the xbox siriusx as well as
the load times quick resume
and the improvements that games are
given when played on the xbox series x
uh michael's done written pieces which
you can find on hit video game website
gamespot.com
and there's also video impressions on
gamespot here and we can check out but
as lucy said we've got a bunch of
questions
for him um and uh these are all
submitted by you
um so i think the first one is going to
come from lucy so
wow it's it's coming from rex farah
through me uh so he asks uh how are the
times
shall we expect more elevator scenes
shout out to mass effect
do they warrant an upgrade to next gen
uh man uh i personally
would think so uh i think this is
because load times
aren't just when you boot up the game or
when you turn on the console
uh when you play a game so i've been
playing a lot of outer worlds and final
fantasy xv
and these are open world games where
you're constantly like transitioning
loading different saves
so it kind of it permeates the entire
experience
and in in a case like red dead where uh
jeff bakler and i if you watch
our coverage on cnet um red dead two
takes
upwards of two over two minutes to load
on on a 1x
and about 30 to 35 or 38 seconds
on the series x so if you know i i
personally think those things are
important because i've been playing on a
nvme
ssd on my pc for quite a long time now
and that's sort of my expectation uh so
when i go back to consoles i
kind of it's like ah yeah these these
damn load times again but
on the series x you get something much
closer to that and i also want to say
that
these are the numbers that you see on
the low time comparison video
or in my written preview or the video
preview those
are games that aren't specifically
optimized to take advantage
of the the velocity architecture
of the series x so these are just like
straight off of uh
working on an internal ssd so you got
the benefits there
and i have seen a lot of uh questions
and concerns about
okay these are backwards compatible
games that are getting like significant
improvements
but you know the thing on people's minds
like games are going to get bigger
they're going to get more detailed
obviously like textures and assets are
going to get bigger
as we get next-gen games specifically
but i think that those games are going
to be optimized
for this hardware so um my my
speculation would be that
even if games do get bigger they're
going to be able to take advantage of
these things because they're going to be
built with that in mind
but straight off the rip like having
backwards compatible games loading in a
matter of 10 seconds instead of a whole
minute
i personally think that's that's a big
deal some people may not think that's
that much of a deal and more power to
you but um
the differences are very noticeable i
think and what was the second there's a
second part of that question uh just do
they warrant an upgrade
uh personally i think so but uh it
really depends
on what what you want to get out of it
that's just one aspect though
uh that i think the series x and you
know
the series s because it's working off of
that same architecture and
a lot of that same hardware i would
think so yeah
all right michael this next question
comes to you from retro kevlar how much
ssd space does the quick resume feature
take up
it would i would assume there is an
amount reserved so you can cash all
those games to the drive
yeah so quick resume isn't going to take
up any extra drive space it's a feature
that's built
into the way the console operates it's
an os
side sort of thing one thing to note
about
you know having space reserved for those
types of features
the the series x comes with a one
terabyte drive but
only 802 gigabytes are available on it
so like with any system a lot of that is
reserved for os
side of things and i'm assuming that
quick resume
is part of that like that that space
that's being used by
the operating system so for our purposes
like
you have that 802 gigabytes completely
free to do whatever you want quick
resume isn't going to affect that
uh so uh you don't need to worry about
like leaving extra space it's just
a way to suspend a game state and just
put it in the background
um so the console will take care of that
user side
you don't need to worry about that um
but on the note of quick resume i do
uh think it's a it's a really dope
feature even if you have like
i was able to successfully suspend up to
six games
there's uh no extra resources that are
being taken up whether it's
you know on the storage drive or in
terms of like
performance when i do jump to another
game uh it's all smooth
at least in my experience so far so yeah
you don't really need to worry about
that
quick resume is just built into the way
the xbox series x works
uh and it's a it's a feature you're
gonna you're gonna use whether you like
it or not
uh just because it's it's not an option
it's not something you enable it's just
something that happens when you back
out of a game and don't manually close
it so
yeah it's all part of that ecosystem you
don't need to worry about anything in
that regard
next question comes from dave jack who
asks can you do a crosston
party ah i have to kind of uh
do a little bit of extrapolation or uh
yeah to answer this question so i've
been playing a few multiplayer games on
the series x
such as halo 5 call of duty warzone
and it all it's all cross
cross gen multiplayer it's just
to me what when the experience is that
i'm simply just using another xbox it's
all part of the same family
it's all part of the same ecosystem it
doesn't
it doesn't look like it makes any
distinctions when you jump into a
multiplayer game just like oh you're
connected to xbox live
let's max match make with everyone who's
playing on xbox live
um of course there's different cases
with cross platform games such as call
of duty
don't need to get into those details
there but um when it comes to parties
since this is just another just another
xbox
you know i can pull up my friends list i
can see everyone it's in the same
system all that stuff uh my speculation
or my extrapolation is that yes you can
do cross-gen
uh parties i can't like 100 confirm that
because i haven't done it myself
i'm sure there are some people out there
who have previewed the series x
that probably have a solid answer on
that but
just based on how i know the how the
system works and my experiences with
multiplayer
that should and probably will be totally
a thing
no problems syed hussein asks does it
support the ultra wide that's 21.9
aspect ratio not natively no so i
actually have a ultra wide monitor here
it's what i use for my pc
and if you do hook it up to an ultrawide
monitor you're going to get some wild
stretching
uh so yeah it's just it's gonna is it is
it like
is it geralt yes no if you want to play
witcher 3
on series x on an ultrawide monitor you
can expect wide geralt
which i'm a fan of but that's not ideal
for the gameplay experience
so yeah you're just going to get a
really stretched image there's no ultra
wide native ultrawide support
built into the thing who knows if
microsoft could accommodate that
in future updates but that's not
something that you should expect now
or in the near future unfortunately
because i love actual uh
extra wide ultra wide 21x9 i don't know
i don't know if you've done it yet but
you should absolutely
like get a picture of what's that um
covenant enemy from halo
there with the donkey oh i'll just say
greg
craig craig get craig's face on that
monitor and just record or take a
screenshot
michael can you choose what resolution
frames you want to play on or is it
constant 4k
60 fps 1080p 120. oh this is a deep
question
um how should i answer this okay
so games are going to run
in the way that they were programmed to
run
so it's not like a pc where you go into
an options menu and choose which
resolution what you want to cap your
frame rate at
um so it's going to be a lot similar
to how xbox one x enhancement works it's
either built into the game
or you're gonna get like performance
mode
full graphics mode resolution priority
mode uh
as i've seen in games such as final
fantasy 15 and
uh monster hunter world which i've also
been playing so it's gonna
it works like that at least so far so
you're not gonna be able to manually
choose your resolution i mean
it also depends on your display because
you can you can go into the options
menu on your xbox itself hardware side
and set the resolution to either 4k
i could also do 1440p on the tv i'm
using or 1080p
no reason why i would use that though
because you're not going to get any
sort of benefit from lowering your
resolution
on your tv or hardware side when you
jump into the game because the game is
going to run the way it's programmed
uh and if you have options for how you
want the game to perform
with 1x enhancements which we're seeing
on the series x
then uh those are your options there so
for example
i tested this the this question now just
the double check
uh so i set my tv to 1080p went to final
fantasy 15
set it on high graphics mode still ran
with 30 frames per second capped
because that's the way the game is uh
programmed to run and then when i go
into a light mode
which is prioritizes frame rate that
runs at
smooth 60 and that's the same
if i jump the the tv up to 4k or jump
the
series x to say hey display 4k um so
yeah there's no like manually switching
graphics options
uh i don't i don't suspect games are
going to be able to
i don't expect games on the series x to
veer off from how 1x enhancements have
worked in the past and currently work
because i think that will add just
another layer of confusion when the
console experience is supposed to be
you're like fairly
seamless where you don't really need to
think about those things uh so yeah
uh that's kind of i guess a long way to
answer
but uh yeah hopefully that that answers
your question and on the on the question
of
120 hertz i haven't had any
games with that enhancement yet i do
expect to see those
soon such as ori and the will of the
wisps
and i'm going to see how that option
actually works i don't suspect it to be
that much different from choosing
enhancement options in the menu
but i will report back when i do see
that
but yeah um on the question of 120 hertz
also depends on what your tv can display
or your monitor
but that's that's a whole another full
can of worms
next question comes from jaybird buckle
up this is a long one
i would like to know if the controller
input lag feels
noticeably better i had read this that
this was a big focus with the new
console
controller not to say the xbox one
controllers were problematic
but i always felt like the ps4
controller had the advantage
this generation in responsiveness owned
both
which which ended up being a proven in a
study
oddly the bluetooth ps4 controller had
the best input lag
even over a hard wired one so the
question is
um what's the input lag like um for
the controller and can you make any
comparisons to existing ones
i love the way they phrase it where it's
like xbox one controllers are
problematic
yeah xbox one controllers are cancelled
cancelling them racist
wow wow well what this this new uh xbox
controller maybe you should just cancel
those uh
those older xbox controls because this
one's actually a lot
it's i like this one a lot more but on
the
on the question of input lag i actually
i can't provide
like technical insight on that uh quite
yet but
i will say that it is very responsive um
if there is and also if there is a
difference between um
latency or input lag between the two
controllers i haven't been able to
notice
i i tested a bunch of things out on xbox
one
also in comparison to this uh on the
same setup
and i also play ps4 on the same setup
and personally i don't
notice a difference between any of them
in terms of input latency or input lag
with
the controller there so but that is
something that
i will i can look much more into as i
test out the
series x more uh going into the the next
wave
of content that we do but on the topic
of the controller
there are i think there are features
into this controller that
i think will make a bigger difference
than uh maybe the input latency that
we've had
because honestly the past controllers
have been working
perfectly fine at least for me uh on my
end
but there are features on the controller
like the share button i think is really
dope the grips
i think are much much better than what
you get
on the the original xbox controller
because there are textured it's like a
plastic texture but it just feels a lot
better to hold
the weight more in line with the seri is
the with the elite
controller closer to the elite yeah yeah
i think the the elite has like
rubberized grips if i recall correctly i
don't know that
that thing is way out of my price range
but i respect it
uh but yeah it's it's kind of like a
middle ground between that because it's
it's like
plasticky texture but it is it is nice
to that it's
it's part of the the way the controller
is built so that's one of the
interesting things that um
it could because the controllers that
currently exist for the xbox
one are forwards comparable right they
work on
the new console so i wonder if the input
lag that um jaybird is feeling could be
tweaked or firmware side um
to make it a bit better um especially
what you would think that would be the
case because microsoft will need to
support the existing elite controllers
so
it may be the chances are either it's
not going to feel all that different or
they'll make some
changes that make it feel slightly
tighter the important thing that i think
you really missed out on is how does it
taste
i can go get it right now if you all
want you want to do a taste test he's
doing it
ladies and gentlemen you are watching
generation next but we have a podcast
within a podcast so welcome to
how does that controller taste joining
us is michael hyam who will be
tasting the brand new xbox series x
controller
now michael hyam is an autonomous person
so we're going to give him to
the freedom to tuck his tongue into any
crevice on the xbox series x controller
that he feels will best give him a taste
of the controller
michael hyam take it away put that
tongue to work
i'm sorry michael i'm sorry relax
uh second off i mean last week last week
we confirmed that you like to really get
up in them guts that makes perfect sense
that this week
okay uh so i'm not going to lick the
handles here because that's where my
hands have been and it's probably just
going to taste like
i don't know you don't get up here if
you lick that
yeah yeah so i i need to lick the front
of the controller while my hands haven't
been
uh so uh yeah here it goes
oh baby microsoft is not going to want
that controller
i mean oh yeah this is a loner
many hands have been on the height yeah
listen my hands have been in this thing
or on this thing
tell us how it tastes michael hyam
it just tastes like not bad not bad at
all that's the official ruling okay
the ruling of next gen the first thing
that everyone said it's not
bad should i taste the console itself
yeah give give the console a little lick
just just get your tongue in one of
those vents oh
relax
not bad tastes like the controller oh
there you have it generation next uh sub
podcast how does that control a slash
hardware taste
official verdict not bad it's not bad
and like i've i've licked a switch
cartridge and they taste
disgusting yeah oh yeah way better than
swiss cartridges that's that is
definitely a huge advantage that xbox
has
over nintendo straight up tastes much
better ranked
you know switch at the bottom well
that's not even a controller that's a
card i'm gonna count it get account of
it yeah yeah
you can't lick digital games i can't
lick any games on game pass that's the
one problem
there you have it who else is doing this
kind of uh next-gen console coverage no
one that's who thank you
michael joshua thompson asks uh this
one's actually
like something i didn't even think of
and honestly michael i feel like you
missed a trick
not doing a jeff keely and just tweeting
out a power chord
and getting like an obscene number
of uh like likes and retweets on it but
can we use the power chord from the one
x
with the series x trying to figure out
if i need to pull my whole entertainment
center out or just swap consoles
that would rock uh yes you can use your
xbox one x
or was it one x specifically power cord
he said he says one x
yeah yes uh because i had i had all my
consoles set up in one area and then
in in light of this question i was like
hey what if i just use my
my xbox one x chord it works what if i
use the one that i use on my ps4
that also worked as well so it's all
it's all the same it's all the same
power chord
uh so it's the same spec i would assume
uh but yeah hey
you know same power chord so uh yeah you
don't gotta you don't gotta rip out your
your center just use the same one maybe
you cross those streams though i can't
believe it
god do it all right michael question of
the century for xbox series x from
savage duck but can it run crisis
at least right now because i have a
limited
uh set of backwards compatible games
that i can
use for this preview period and crisis
is not one of them so i personally can't
confirm if it can run crisis
but word on the street is that it can
but hey
listen people be saying a lot of
different things uh who knows if it's
true
we'll see man all right we got we got
one more question
and then we'll let you go michael we're
sorry we're sorry
michael hyam liquor extraordinaire final
question
comes from yoshi187
does the series x also serve as a secret
mini fridge
or even just a regular sized fridge no
don't
no no there's no like listen i can't
speak on the thermals quite yet
but you don't want to be putting
anything
in here you don't want to be putting any
any of your soda cans and your
your brewskis any of your your truly
lemonade cans
as a blessing and i have been uh rolling
through those really quickly
hell yeah but you can't even like slot a
bit of ham in
in this just a slice i think i can do
that just a slice of him
there's a disc drive in everything it's
the perfect i'm gonna get my sandwich
meat in here
i love oh grim i love how that console
seems
i love sandwich meat is that what the
kids are calling it these days
all right i love i like relax
i love that that console seems
specifically designed to counter can it
blend
the the youtube channel just because
it's like well let's see you try and get
this into a blender
oh my god not a secret minifigure fridge
sorry nope sorry i hate to see it but um
facts is facts
all right before we kind of just you
know devolve into us all doing
uh yoshi impressions thank you so much
everyone who asked questions
big thank you to michael um make sure to
go
to youtube.com gamespot games.com
michael what are the pieces um the
people should be looking out for
about your series x coverage yeah if you
want to get the broad
overview that uh some of the things that
we couldn't touch on today
definitely check out my written preview
on gamespot.com
check out the the video version on
youtube and on gamespot if you rather
watch me go through all of those things
and see
my my pretty mug again great you want to
do that
look yeah uh and also you can check out
uh cnet uh
cnet also has a thing where i'm on it
with jeff bakalar
him and i go back and forth with each
other so go back
and forth
[Laughter]
was that worth interrupting for no but
did i do it yes
so please check that out we had a we had
a really good time
uh jeff is a wonderful person and we
kind of go through a lot of those um
those hands-on experience types of
things so you can get a lot more details
there as well and
i'm gonna be you know we have a low time
comparison so you can see exactly how
the load times line up between the
series x
and the xbox one x on a handful of games
i am going to be continually updating
those things as well testing out more
load times testing out different types
of drives with this thing
uh also i have a whole thing on quick
resume which i'm also going to be
updating
uh based on that because i do think it's
a really cool feature that you should
get more details on to see how all that
stuff works but yeah i got you all
covered and if there's anything else you
want to know
hit us up excellent and michael where
are you on twitter that people can find
you
you can feed five you can find my phone
for fun you can feedback on me
uh you can find me and all of my all my
stuff on
twitter at michael p hyam i'm going to
be sharing a lot of stuff there
not related to xbox but also related to
xbox so uh yeah keep up with my stuff
man i really appreciate that
uh time about you uh you found me on
twitter uh tomorrow h just doing stuff
jordan find me on twitter at jmrme
and i'm at least james games join us
again next week where
maybe sony will do something i don't
know maybe who knows
send us send me a ps5 let me let me
taste it
let's taste test yeah
better taste like oreos
all right we'll see you next week ice
cream sandwich
you